a popular tv show and netflix movie have
put midwifery in the spotlight thanks
for joining us
at 6 30 i'm christian casadas and i'm
denise valdez call the midwife is a bbc
show about a group of nurse midwives in
london in the 1950s
and then pieces of a woman is a netflix
movie about a woman grappling with a
devastating home birth according to the
southern nevada health district out of
the more than
79 000 births in clark county over the
past three years
just 1200 have been home births well one
southern nevada woman who chose to have
a midwife
rather than a doctor care for her during
her pregnancy is now sharing her story
the i-team's vanessa murphy breaks down
the role of midwives
and why this new mother is now suing the
midwife she chose for her home birth
denise midwifery has been around for
centuries but it is not
regulated in the state of nevada some
midwives work with physicians
others do not an expectant mother may go
to a midwife instead of a doctor for
care and checkups
and in some cases choose to deliver in
their homes
now here in clark county a mother is
suing the midwife who cared for her
during her pregnancy
and both sides are sharing their
versions of what happened
one two three i'm pregnant
this is alicia sauers and her husband
telling their family she was pregnant
with a due date in may of 2020.
really a dream come true sauers says she
and her husband chose home birth due to
concerns about going to a hospital
during the kovit 19 pandemic
and they considered their home to be a
special place
turns out sowers was having twins while
her second child survived after she was
rushed to the hospital
the sours lost their firstborn and
her son sullivan was born gray
and not breathing now there's a
disagreement over how her pregnancy
unfolded along with what started as a
home birth
the sours are suing well-rounded mama
the woman who runs at cherry hopkins
and three other members of her team
sauers alleges negligence breach of
contract and breach of fiduciary duty
hopkins and torrey hinkle who is also
named as a defendant
agreed to an interview with the i-team
to respond to the allegations
hopkins says she was in charge to me the
truth is on my side what we found
two different versions of the same
events yeah
i had all sorts of confidence in her
it felt like a friendship you know
according to the lawsuit on or about
april 4 hopkins began suspecting saurs
was having twins
but failed to transfer care it continues
on may 2nd
an ultrasound which confirmed she was
carrying twins who were shearing
the same sack and placenta referred to
as monomono
according to columbia university's
obstetrics and gynecology website
for twins sharing the same sac and
placenta there's a chance their
umbilical cords could be entangled
and lead to the loss of one or both of
their lives
that's why this type of pregnancy is
closely monitored
the lawsuit alleges sauers then
anticipated having to register at a
hospital
but hopkins asserted home birth was
still an option
and had you seen an ob gyn at all
no hopkins and hinkle describe sours as
being resistant to take their advice
their attorney says there is still no
confirmation the twins shared the same
sack and placenta
because he claims sauvers refused to get
a diagnostic ultrasound
hopkins says sauers was resistant to
getting an ultrasound throughout the
pregnancy
even after her recommendations starting
at 20 weeks
if there are so many risks is it time to
say
you need to deliver at the hospital well
i guess that wouldn't be left up to me i
would never
again you're talking about removing
parents choices
by telling them what they can and can't
do hopkins says a major principle of
midwifery
is body autonomy while sowers chose
midwifery over a medical doctor
she is now questioning hopkins and her
team's qualifications
how much research did you do
about qualifications and her background
and
not enough obviously um
it hurt she she really
explained her experience and her
certifications and she took our
insurance and the insurance told us
you know that she was covered and we
were good to go and i felt like that
made it very
legitimate but when you really dive into
it
none of it really carries any weight
according to hopkins website she's been
a certified professional midwife since
2011. the north american registry of
professional midwives states
a certified professional midwife's
competency is established through
training education and supervised
clinical experience
followed by successful completion of a
written examination
i do keep medical charts authenticated
medical charts it's all
online it's all electronic every time we
had a conversation with miss
hours every time she refused something
she signed
documentation stating she knew exactly
what my training was
according to hopkins attorney those
documents could not be provided to the
i-team
he says he and sauer's attorney reached
an agreement hopkins could only
discuss sauer's care for this report
matthew hoffman is the sauers attorney
well this was a risk that the company
was in a unique
position to know they were not equipped
to handle
and they had a duty to tell our clients
hey we can't do this safely
and they didn't why hopkins says this is
the first
loss of her career we have all
shed tears over her loss and for this
family as they have grieved
sowers keeps sullivan's ashes close
we we cremated him i actually have some
of his remains
in this ring she says she and her
husband continue to try to cope with the
loss
of their child it just broke our hearts
sauers says she believes home births and
midwives need to be
regulated